تفتخر ايران من خلال مقاطع البروباغندا
التي تبثها قنواتها بما تنتجه مصانعها من
مسيرات قتاليه ولكن ما كشفته حرب اوكرانيا
هو ان المسيرات ايرانيه الصنع التي
استخدمتها القوات الروسيه لضرب البنى
التحتيه والمناطق المدنيه الاوكرانيه ليست
صناعه ايرانيه خالصه
شظايا المسيارات الايرانيه التي تم
تحليلها في اوكرانيا تحتوي على مكونات
الكترونيه مصنوعه في دول مختلفه ومنها
الولايات المتحده هنا تريد واشنطن لعب دور
فعال في تعطيل صناعه السيارات الايرانيه
من خلال العقوبات على الافراد والشركات
التي تزود طهران بمكونات الكترونيه كشركه
القدسي التابعه للحرس الثوري الايراني
وشركه باربار باريس لتكنولوجيا الطيران
واشنطن في سعيها لايقاف امداد روسيا بهذه
المسيرات الانتحاريه وضعت شريكتي طيران من
ايران متورطتين في نقل المسيرات الى
القوات الروسيه في لائحه العقوبه حتى ان
لم تستطع امريكا ايقاف التصنيع قد تؤدي
الى ارقله عمليه التسليم للمستخدم النهائي
ضوابط التصدير سيكون لها تاثير ولكن علينا
ان نكون واقعيين بشان الجداول الزمنيه لكن
الدول المصممه ستضع يدها على التكنولوجيا
للتطبيقات الدفاعيه المتخصصه او تعديلات
تصميمات اسلحتها وفقا لما يمكنهم الحصول
عليها حتى لو كانت اقل موثوقيه
والى حين نجاح المجهودات الامريكيه
والغربيه في ايقاف برنامج المسيارات
الايرانيه تعتزم روسيا تزويد ايران
بمكونات عسكريه متطوره مقابل 3
ايرانيه التي استخدمتها في اوكرانيا ما
يسهم في تقويض الامن في الشرق الاوسط
والعالم
انس نماسي العربيه